what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be giving a little
backstory on
my family um we kind of have an
interesting story so i thought i would
share it with you
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring my
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay small thing before i start this is
my instagram just pearly things with the
z
follow it that way i'm just trying to be
monetized on instagram i'm just going to
be honest i'm trying to get monetized on
instagram
it'd be cool if you guys would follow if
not still enjoy the video
okay so this is how my family started my
mom
met my dad when my mom was 18 and my dad
was 23. um so they met
got pregnant with my oldest brother
greg now greg was an
accident clearly um so they ended up
giving up greg for adoption and i did
not meet him till
i was 22 so that's the end of that
um you know like he came back in the
picture later that's just
a whole different story so growing up
so actually before i started that then
when my parents i couldn't find a
picture that was like old i probably
could if i asked my mom but
when my mom she like she's probably in
her 30s or 40s here but
when my mom was 20
uh 1 or 22 my dad was like 26 or 27
right after they got married they
adopted my
second my um older sister mary but
mary was like 15 when she adopted when
they adopted her so she really
was just like a bad situation they
adopted her she moved out when i was a
year old so i really didn't grow up with
her but
she's also part of the family literally
love her um
okay so then the rest of us came so this
is what i grew up with so
from the age of like one till
i was 18 this is like the family
structure i had
i was the second oldest and i didn't
know about greg
my whole life so my head i was the
second oldest um
i know i peaked in high school i was so
pretty
so that's my brother austin that's my
brother adam um that's gabrielle eva and
amelia and i literally like love being
in a big family and i really enjoyed
growing up between two boys um i really
like love both of my brothers a lot
so i don't know i just enjoyed being in
between both of them
adam's been on the channel before and
austin probably will soon i have a video
with him i just haven't edited it yet
okay so we grow up whatever things are
cool
then um so when i went to off to college
so this is
all my college pictures i turned 18
and let's see so then
we adopted brian
let's see if i can find a picture with
him um
so brian also was older he was like 16
or 17 when we adopted him
and yeah so we he came in late
and he like lived with our family for a
couple years oh here he is
so that is brian after that
um there was another there's a kid
on my brother's football team that also
wasn't in a good
situation so he wasn't related to us at
all
um and it was weird my brother just like
brought him home
one day and then
like literally he just like moved in
and they ended up adopting him too his
name was chat well it is
chaz and i'm trying to find
a picture with him
see that's my that's my brother austin
groan oh here he is okay
so this is like a christmas picture from
one year so yeah then chaz
came into the family and this is
everyone
um that's my friend brooke she just
crashed pictures that year
um yeah and then when i was 22
i found out about my oldest brother greg
and so that was all 10 of us so
kind of a crazy story i just thought you
guys would enjoy it
please follow me on instagram and let me
know in the comments if you guys have
any questions but
yeah don't forget to subscribe